missile for just sweet Harry very he is
one of the greatest pop singers in
history she came out and this spotlight
was on her and she absolutely came to
life she's made something very
spine-tingling just a few minutes cher
is gonna be up on that balcony
singing Fernando can you believe that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every time you offer someone a part you
have to have the next person in mind but
in this case there were suddenly one
there was his share I come in in a
helicopter and then I land and I come
walking up with a cane and I'm I'm
different
let's get the party started cher playing
my mother of course when I used to hear
Abba is so fabulous I mean the lyrics
just totally grabbed me
it's things I felt a million times so it
was easy to sing it was so much fun to
see her she was divine
the anticipation made the air crackle
it's absolutely fabulous sheer talent of
the lady acting C and being shared to
hear her sing Fernando she was perfect
for that song
[Music]
all of a sudden you have chair and about
together
it's exciting anything it was just
amazing to Kai I have never felt closer
to mom I'm in the exact same place that
she was all those years ago you're
pregnant
yeah tonight
it's a night for celebration come on
let's get this show on the road I was
told you couldn't come I'm a spontaneous
person no you're not no I'm not
[Music]
these are my dad's it takes three great
men to create such a woman we never did
ask you guys what happened when you met
my mother I don't know it may feature
holes but the world is wide I want to
make some memories there's an island
cala Carrie people used to think if you
sailed on from there you'd fall off the
edge of the world sounds like the place
for me
[Music]
unbell I'm Donna he is literally the
handsomest man in the world
sucker this guy this whole place is
incredible
I think we should stay here together may
the rest of our lives be the best of our
lives just tell me you didn't invite
your grandmother Wicked Witch of the
West I've decided to commit to being a
grandmother grandma you weren't invited
that's the best kind of party little
girl
[Music]
my soulmate may actually be carved the
line must be wine all three of us are
grandfathers that's that
[Music]
look what you've done with the place she
wanted to make a mum proud if she hasn't
done that all her life
[Music]
we can't tell anybody about the baby yet
I just told bill yeah and I told Harry I
told many many people got about to
become a grandmother great-grandmother
I'm living that out of the bio
[Music]
you